so yeah my guy is um
dan gilbert um and the reason i thought
he was super interesting i've talked
about him a little bit in the past but
this guy has had a freaking massive year
so uh you know two years ago or
something
he was worth like six seven eight
billion dollars
uh baby billionaire now he's worth 57
billion wait
five minutes seven five seven fifty
seven he's number twenty one one of the
wealthiest people in the united states
um
and this is he's had a crazy couple
years so i think it was about two years
ago
he had a massive stroke so he was on the
golf course with a friend
and uh the doc the friend just happened
to be a doctor and he said oh that's
weird i'm having these symptoms
so his doctor got him to the hospital
and
they he had a stroke in the hospital
and in the hospital they were able to do
this special procedure that if he hadn't
been in the hospital he might have died
or it might have been way worse right
so he got super lucky yeah and you know
as lucky as one can be having a stroke
horrible thing
and uh now he's been basically
rehabilitating himself and getting back
on his feet for last two years
and so he's had this horrible personal
tragedy but at the same time he's become
worth
you know 6x uh you know as much and i
bet he would give it all away to not
have had the stroke or
whatever so it's super fascinating um
this guy
he described it really well when they
ipo'd they just ipo'd his mortgage
business
he said this is a 30-year or sorry an
overnight success
30 years in the making so this guy's
been at it for a really long time
i think he's super interesting because
he started with nothing
um his dad owned a struggling detroit
bar
he worked in pizza delivery he just kind
of stumbled into hustling
and was a good sales person and he
started a business
and that business was a company called
rock financial which became quicken
loans which i'll talk about in a second
um one of the reasons i think he's
really interested interesting is that
he's invested into revitalizing his home
city
so his mission is to revitalize detroit
and get it back on its feet because it's
struggled a lot
um he's like a capitalist batman in
detroit
and i'll talk about some of the cool
stuff he's done um and one of the things
i like about him as well is that he
uh he uh does a lot of stuff that might
not work
he takes big swings takes big risks that
he think can make the world better
um and he invests in all sorts of crazy
ideas uh he also has five kids
which i think is pretty freaking cool uh
i love to see that with
these you know billionaires they're not
just like miserable by themselves and
they care about kids and stuff
and seems pretty family focused um and
then you know he's been through these
personal challenges this stroke
and then also his eldest son was born
with this disease called
neurofibromatosis which is like super
rare
and he's poured a bunch of money uh his
own money into funding research around
that
disease so it's been fascinating um
so he said uh there's a quote he said
when i when we grew up
all i wanted to do was do two things own
a sports team
and a casino and now he owns both so
this is kind of like a childhood dream
and his companies are quicken loans
which is the largest home mortgage
lender in the united states they're
bigger than wells fargo which is
freaking crazy
uh he owns the cleveland cavaliers the
basketball team and a few other sports
franchises
until recently he owned a casino i think
it was called jack
which owned a whole bunch of casinos but
i think he sold it and then he also owns
rock ventures and rock ventures is where
all the big
swings happen and all the philanthropic
stuff happens so
um they own a ton of real estate almost
all in detroit
and then they do venture capital and
they've invested in
everything from uh restaurants to
uh you know real estate businesses
hotels
crazy tech companies and all sorts of
other stuff he owns
rob report which is like one more thing
can i tell you a few more things that he
owns that's interesting
um so he owns i think he owns fat head
do you know fat head
yeah yeah i believe sports it's like
those like big hands and stuff and like
yeah yeah
weird if you're a kid and you want to
put like a
like the face of michael jordan on your
wall it's like a decal that you put on
your wall i think he owns the whole
thing
he just bought dictionary.com and
thesaurus.com
um totally random we were actually we
helped him i know him i'll talk about
that a little bit but uh we helped him
with that acquisition a little bit oh no
way so you know about it it was like a
it's like a 20 million dollar revenue
thing or more maybe
um it's been doing that for like 10
years i i mean i don't have any insider
information
these are guesses um and am i right
yeah yeah he owns dictionary.com and
thesaurus.com
um and like when you talk to him about
why he bought it he's just like
you know i think this is cool like he's
just like i had all these ideas of
things i could do with it
he's not like going oh i bought it for x
times ebitda and i'm gonna make a 20
return and this is what i find so cool
about this guy is he'll just say yes
so he owns like rob report which is like
a magazine for rich people
dictionary.com um he owns or has a very
large stake in shinola
so shinola has this like insane hotel in
detroit
they make watches uh he owns stockx
which is like a
it's basically like a stock market for
sneakers and watches
which is awesome because like he
co-founded it he's i know
he's like in his hell is he in the 70s
yet he's like 50
50 something 56 i think he's that young
wow okay
that's a little bit older than like a
sneaker head
uh and he totally i he's a co-founder i
didn't know that so he was it he
esports he's got investments in esports
like just
all sorts of stuff and then he's also a
large lp and a lot of venture funds kind
of quietly like he's the largest lp in
ludlow ventures
he's got his own venture fund and so you
look at it and he's got this barbell
right he's got a really kind of dull
boring
you know mortgage business which is
really innovative in and of itself just
what he's done is kind of like brad
what he's done is like basically taken
this fragmented
crappy industry run by banks and small
lenders and like built out this massive
structure
and been very innovative around culture
and other stuff
so let me let me just give the history
of what happened though so
basically in 1985 him and his little
brother
uh start rock financial which is
basically a
independent mortgage lender so when
someone you know needs a house or
whatever it is they go to them
they figure out they basically make them
an offer
to lend them the money and then i think
they go sell the risk so they would lend
them the money
and then they would sell it off to a
bank over time um
and basically in the late 1990s company
grew into a huge
business one of the largest uh
independent in the united states
and with the dot-com boom they launched
an internet strategy
where they just made uh rock financial i
think it was rockfinancial.com or
digitalmortgage.com or something like
that and
in uh and in 2000
what was it no 1997 or something
intuit acquired their business because
they were like oh my god this is like
you know this huge
disruptive digital finance thing and so
um what ended up happening is the
dot-com boom blew up
and in 2002 he came back and he bought
his business back so he sold it for a
ton of money
into it first sale was 90 million
okay is that right he basically i i
don't know i don't have the exact number
here
but um something like that so you know
the guy made a lot of money
especially for the 90s but he wasn't
like a crazy billionaire yet
then he raised money from investors so
himself
and some friends went back to intuit
bought it back
i don't know what the number was and
what's interesting is they kept the
quicken loans name
so intuit owns quicken the financial
personal finance software
and they branded it quicken and so now
there's this weird other business they
own called quicken loans even though
that's an intuit brand so it's kind of a
funny
uh thing and it just kept hibiscus he
took it
took it back got rid of all the crap
into it that added
and started growing at a great again and
this whole time he's living in detroit
and watching his own city totally fall
apart
so in the financial crisis uh you know
detroit i think went bankrupt
and he meanwhile is like super rich and
living out in the suburbs
and he says [__] it we're moving back
into detroit and he moves his entire
team
uh into detroit so he had four thousand
or so
uh employees they literally bought if
you actually go to detroit there's this
um
it's called campus martius or something
and it's right in the center of downtown
this huge building
and he moved everywhere and there and he
basically said
for my own employees and for the city
we're just going to fix it
and so he built uh casinos he built like
a private security
uh firm so if you walk around there's
like there's like normal police and then
there's like dan's police
um he bought billions of dollars of
derelict buildings
uh you know literally like you go there
and there's like skyscrapers
and he's just it's like going to chicago
and he's like oh yeah i own the sears
tower
and this and this and like basically all
of downtown detroit he owns like 20 30
percent of
and um he also just announced that he's
going to pay off 300 million dollars of
property taxes
for detroit residences so this guy
really really cares
about detroit and since since he started
it
it's now become the largest uh
independent mortgage business in in the
united states
uh you know they've gone public they had
this huge ipo
um and it's been it's been a crazy story
i love about this guy is just he's got
such a crazy collection of businesses
i think if i remember correctly i think
i'm probably i think i'm right
but i believe he sold it for 90 he
bought it back for like
20 and i think he took it public did he
take it public like
either recently or right away quite
recently like it was like
like uh six months ago and he owned most
of it when it went public
he owned like 85 or 90 of it and
it went totally crazy what's the market
cap now
the market cap is let's see here market
caps 46 billion dollars
wow so yeah where's the other 10 billion
come from just as other
just as otherwise a lot yeah a lot of
real estate you think the cavaliers are
probably worth you know five hundred
million twenty
we've forgotten about that whole part
you know all these stockx is worth i
think a couple billion dollars now
um so he's just got this crazy
collection of stuff and
and so chris and i got to meet him um
the other cool thing about this guy is
like he's just a wild card
like i so i read about him in the new
york times they did this profile of him
and i i have this habit of just cold
emailing people i think are interesting
and like 95
of the time i just don't hear back but i
wrote him an email
at like one in the morning and said hey
you you know i'd love to meet you
and i get an email back like five
minutes later and he's just like
yeah sure and then i got a follow-up
from his assistant
and we ended up flying to detroit and it
you know sometimes when you go and meet
these billionaires they're like
whatever you know you walk in you get 20
minutes with them
that's that he was like incredible they
like
planned this whole tour of detroit it
was like this two-day thing
like ever they set us up in their hotel
um and then dan spent like two hours
with us
and he's just this super nice guy he's
like deeply interested in what we're
doing
um and super engaged and like every
business i mentioned to him
he'd be like how does that work how can
we get involved what can we do
how can we do it like he wants to say
yes to ideas which i always find really
inspiring right because i think
some of these people have gotten really
rich they've gotten rich by being like
hyper disciplined and just saying no to
everything
but he says yes before no that's really
interesting that's what shawn acts like
and i usually i usually say no to
everything sean says yes to everything
and my joke is that like
i'm like my success is probably gonna be
quite predictable and it will be
really good sean's success is he's gonna
go completely broke and die
like young or he's gonna become a
billionaire
super fat like you know it's like a it's
a high risk high reward
thing and that's not the reality but
that's my joke
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back